- I think way too many people,
when they think
they're a manager,
think people
are working for them
and I think when
people are mentors,
they think that they're
working for the other person
and I think all the best
managers are actually mentors.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
("Spirits" by Rowlan)
- [Gary] The reason I give
away all my content
is the magic is in
the last mile, right.
It's the last, it's the details
and the unique situation
of business for an entrepreneur,
that actually matter.
Right, like I can get people
to third and a half base,
third and three-quarters base,
but I can
change people's business
if I'm in front of them.
If they just give
me all the details,
and it goes from being
philosophical to practical
and so the way it differs
when I'm actually consulting
or mentoring, or am part of a
board, or a marketing board,
or an investor and
I want the outcome to work
is I'm actually looking at
every detail of the situation
and I'm bringing value within
context, not just theoretical.
This is not my release,
you know, like...
So, what we need to do
is strike where
I think the opportunity is,
which is why the
travsyum laid out is white.
Is anybody paying attention
to anything I'm saying?
Like, it's all noise to me.
Everything matters,
information matters,
but not the cliche thing that
everybody does all the time.
Really great, had
a huge client pitch.
Did you get some B-roll?
Kinda, sorta?
Kinda, sorta.
- [DRock] All of their
faces were in the shot.
I had a client pitch,
I just signed this one.
Went really well, big one.
Now a talk about
VaynerMedia's social
and then take care of
that, get serious about that.
Our workout this
morning was tough.
I also ate way too
much guacamole last night.
I ate so much guacamole, Rene.
- [Rene] I didn't
know you eat that.
- How was that last
night, it was great, right?
- [Rene] It was
good, it was fun, yeah.
- It was like, that's
like good shit, right?
- [Rene] I think that, yeah.
- Last night I ate, some of you
guys didn't see in the vlog,
was, I had, what did
we have, about 15 of us?
- [Rene] Yeah.
- 15 just different groups of
people, that work at Vayner.
- [Rene] It was nice
to meet other people--
- You met a bunch of new people.
- [Rene] Like, I hadn't really--
- Show other people,
DRock, show Rene.
What was that again?
- I said I hadn't
really ever talked
to a lot of those people.
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- [Rene] So it was nice to.
- When you're running a big--
- [Rene] They're bigger, so...
- When you're
running a big organization,
you gotta force serendipity
sometimes, so that was good.
Things are good.
Nicholson's here.
(laughing)
How you been?
Everything's well? Get in here.
Very well,
good to see you again.
Tomorrow, what time we
putting it on, about 10 or 11?
Tomorrow, 9:30 A.M.
How to Start, one of the
best films we've ever made
and really the
film that most people
on YouTube and
the internet,
the world need to watch.
There's so many people in here
that shouldn't
be producing video,
because that is not the
best way they communicate.
Only a decade ago,
if I was speaking here,
all I would be
talking about is blogging.
High Line's packed.
Behind you, DRock.
This office is
gonna be so proper.
Next summer.
Even this summer.
I don't, I don't, I don't
ask questions, I answer them.
(laughing)
Ask 'em, ask 'em why
common sense isn't factored
into the equation
in marketing today.
I'm being dead serious,
that's actually my question.
When they, when they feel like
they've got something to say,
and got experience
and have the emotions
around actually giving back.
I don't think
there's an official line.
I think anybody,
who's a good manager
has mentorship DNA within them.
I think way too many people,
when they think
they're a manager
think people
are working for them
and I think when
people are mentors,
they think that they're
working for the other person
and I think all the best
managers are actually mentors.
I'm always, I actually
think about it all the time,
because I'm
always thinking about
how do I provide more value
as a businessman, as an owner,
as a leader, as a
personality with my audience.
My natural default
is to be a head coach,
a mentor, a big
brother, a leader.
I think the reason I'm
such a fan of mentorship
is it equates to actual legacy.
Legacy comes in the form of
what people say about you,
when you're not around
and being a great mentor
and advisor leads
to those opportunities.
- [Andy] We're gonna go
around, hopefully you have
two to three ideas on
good video, good video ideas,
that Justin and Iris can create.
Those 14 videos, we're gonna
build and create and support
through Ivy's stories, through
designs, through graphics,
through distribution, through
planning and project managing.
Davio is gonna help with
specific tactical videos,
aka YouTube Subscribe, Download
My Podcast and other like,
Danny has a great idea about
specific Instagram video.
These two are busy.
Davio's gonna
step in and make it.
- Especially on like
Facebook, not just like
the same old title,
square type thing, so...
More vertical stuff,
different things like that.
Instagram, how we
just have like the regular
meme template, yeah, like just--
- [Andy] Switching it up, yeah.
But it's the same
reason why I say like,
we really need a
thing about the headlines,
the title graphics,
you know, thumb stoppers.
- Right, yeah, thumb stoppers.
- The mobile phone (laughs).
Once we like
feed you guys content,
you can visualize like,
"Hmmm, this is
probably a good vertical one,
"or like this is a good one
to try and break something,"
and do like, like,
you know what I mean?
Taking whatever
content you're trying to create
and be like, "I think this
would be a good format for it,"
yeah.
- Yeah, Instagram see.
- [Woman] Yeah, I know.
(crosstalk)
- Come on, Craig.
You got a wool
sweater on. (laughing)
- [Woman] No, I'm feeling it.
- [Andy] Two big things.
Last year is actually
and it was Gary's idea
and I, again, I was bitter
about it, 'cause it's his idea,
but it was one of the
best things that our team did.
He said he wanted
to have a competition,
he's like, "Andy,
break the team up
"into like teams of three
"and the job is you
guys have to create a video
"and the team that
creates the best video wins,"
and what happened, like, we
created five amazing videos
and they are some of the
best videos we have made,
but nothing else
had really changed.
It was just like all of a
sudden, we had the mentality
that's like, "Oh, let's fucking
make an awesome video,"
and sometimes, like when
we add on these people on,
I'm like trying to have other
people manage everything.
We lose that mentality,
and you're just like,
"Oh, this is what Elliot wants,
"let's just give it to Elliot,"
but you don't
necessarily believe in it.
Like, it's a balance
of trying to destroy that
and just create the best things.
like, you want it left.
Cool, if you, very
rarely would Elliot be like,
"Hey, let's try
this meme style,"
and me be like,
"No, definitely not.
"We're sticking to this format."
You know.
Yeah, and other than that,
let's just take this energy
and keep making good things.
And thinking of like, I think
my idea of using music,
Jay creating music,
and I think everyone
else has another similar idea,
that we can start doing.
- [Man] Like (inaudible)?
- [Eliot] Oh!
- One more, one more, one more.
Silent film, I think
we need to try this out.
- [Iris] Oh,
you mean like,
just walking round in his--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Office?
- No music.
(crosstalk)
- [Eliot] DRock, where you
gonna make a video of that?
- I want, yeah, or daily, I
would like a DailyVee when--
- [Man 2] You did, right.
- A DailyVee, DailyVee
where Gary never talks.
It's everyone else talking
and just shows him listening.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And it's about how,
'cause all you ever hear
is how loud he is and
how much he interrupts
and how big he is,
but he really does listen.
- [DRock] The problem is
most of the time what people
are talking about
we can't use their audio.
- Yeah.
- Meaning when I'm talking to
Gary and I say, "DRock sucks,"
we don't want that.
Oh boy (laughs)
Cool, yeah, we have a big team.
We have three designers,
seven video people
and a whole lot
of other characters.
Seth joins in two weeks.
Vayner social will
be a cool way for us
to expand our capabilities.
- [Davielle] Good.
(laughing)
(hip hop music)